hi everybody
it's great to be here with you today my
name is Jen Fitzpatrick and I lead our
geo group here at Google
my team is obsessed with understanding
everything there is to know about the
real world and we want to bring that
insight and understanding of the real
world to people around the globe helping
them navigate explore and decide with
confidence we do this with three main
experiences Google Maps which lets you
leave home knowing that you'll never get
lost
local search the ability to come to
Google and ask anything you might need
to know about a local business whether
it's one in your neighborhood or one far
around the world and Google my business
which enables millions of businesses to
be found on Google and share what's most
unique about them over a billion people
around the world now use Google Maps and
local search but the impact doesn't stop
there we also see incredible opportunity
for businesses to benefit from this deep
understanding of location in the real
world and I'm really excited about
partnering with everyone here today to
build location-based products and
services that have a big big impact on
your businesses too I wanted to start
today by jumping back in time a little
bit it's not too long ago that if you
wanted to go someplace unfamiliar you
had to pull out a paper Atlas and plan
your route in advance didn't even
remember having that experience feels
like kind of a distant memory but I'm
pretty sure most of us can think back to
a time when that was the default so 11
years ago Google Maps set out with the
audacious goal of mapping the world we
wanted to digitize those paper maps and
the paper yellow pages - and we wanted
to do it not just for one neighborhood
or even one country we wanted to do it
for the entire world every street and
every surface every business every
detail all of it since then
we've not only brought Maps online
all around the world we've also done
things like help people experience
corners of the planet that meant that
they might otherwise never get to see
from the tops of the highest mountains
to the depths of the oceans and of
course along the way
we brought all those experiences on
immobilizes as well giving users
everywhere a trusted guide to the real
world that they can bring with them
anywhere to help them get where they're
going fast and to find the best places
to visit along the way to build these
sorts of powerful user experiences we've
had to also build out an incredibly rich
and complex understanding of the real
world and it turns out that the
underlying data that powers these
consumer mapping experiences can also
fuel some incredibly powerful enterprise
use cases as well today we have over
three million developers and ten over
10,000 paying customers using our Maps
API is to do everything from visualizing
points on a map to routing and planning
for deliveries to doing things like
pre-programming TV remotes based on
their location and looking forward we're
building on these capabilities and
bringing together all of our both
historical and real-time knowledge about
the world combining it with things like
machine learning and our club computer
code compute capabilities and using that
to provide business with even more
insights and predictive capabilities so
today I want to share with you three key
ways that we're seeing enterprises
currently take advantage of our Google
Maps data and services to help grow
their businesses and also share some
examples of what we think is possible
together today we see clearly how Google
Maps can help you build better
experiences for your customers how it
can help you optimize your business and
how it can help enable smart strategic
decisions so I talked earlier today
about how we're constantly seeking ways
to make our consumers experiences better
with Google Maps and we see that same
appetite from our enterprise partners
finding ways to use the power of Google
Maps to deliver better experiences to
their end users for example we see auto
companies like Audi Tesla and
you leveraging our local business
listings and their internet systems to
help their drivers easily fine and get
to millions of businesses and points of
interest around the world and we've also
helped transform how how people are
getting around today by doing things
like powering the base maps and
navigation experiences for companies
like uber lyft and others in retail
we're helping companies like Crate &
Barrel Target and Best Buy connect
online actions to offline foot traffic
and in doing so helping them to drive
more feet into their stores and we see
savvy online sellers also you doing
things like taking advantage of our
autocomplete capabilities to make it
easier for the users to type an address
into their shopping cart it does things
like lead directly to fewer abandoned
carts and increase conversion rates let
me talk about a fun one for a minute if
you remember going to Disney World and
getting a giant complicated paper map of
the park and it's crowded you're trying
to figure out how do I get to space now
no no no if I go there right now is the
line gonna be super long right Disney's
a super fun place that can also be
overwhelming and incredibly frustrating
and so Disney Parks had this grand
vision of building an in part and park
app experience that would let you do
everything from understand what the wait
times were to make reservations for the
rides you wanted to go to and help you
easily get around anywhere in the park
well it turns out that to do these
things well one of the things you need
is an incredibly detailed highly -
highly detailed digital map of every
corner of Disney and so several years
back we embarked on a long-term
multi-year partnership with Disney to
create just that and as we got into it
along the way we discovered that there
was a lot more we could do beyond that -
fun things like enabling contextual
location-based experiences so if you've
got a son or a daughter who's really
into goofy you can get a notification in
real time that tells you when goofy
happens to be nearby we also did things
like incorporating all the impart
transit systems and lighting up
turn-by-turn directions so now you can
literally find the fastest way to get to
Splash Mountain right now whether it's
walking or taking them on a rail so it's
a really fun project for us a great
partnership
and we're super pleased to have helped
make the happiest place on earth just a
little bit happier for all of disneys
many visitors let's talk about another
phone when briefly you just heard about
pokemons go from Phil and crew and their
stories are sort of phenomenal example
of what's possible today for consumer
experiences leveraging Google Maps right
pokey [ __ ] took our mapping data and
build an incredible augmented reality
game on top of it and if their early
success is any indication we fully
expect that we're gonna see a lot more
fun and interesting augmented reality
experiences coming in the near future
both for consumers and for enterprises
here's another one as the Internet of
Things scales up location services are
becoming even more essential for
creating smart experiences I mean I
don't know about you but who woulda
thought a few years ago that everything
from your thermostat to your light bulb
to your refrigerator is going to be
connected and can be able to be
controlled by your smartphone but it's
not so crazy to think about in fact it's
not so crazy at this point to think
about a world in the not-too-distant
future where literally every device in
your household is connected in one way
or another and so imagine how cool will
be if your light switches and
thermostats know that you're about to
pull into your driveway and it's new
coming home not your kids and so it can
turn on your lights and the air
conditioning according to your
preferences right before you get home or
knowing your car's about to pull into
the driveway your alarm and your door
lock and automatically disarmed so you
can carry your groceries into the house
without having to put them down all
right in a connected world location
awareness can fuel all sorts of new and
fun ways to interact with the things in
our physical surroundings that gives you
a very brief taste of some of the many
ways that we are seeing businesses build
really game-changing experiences for
their customers on top of our data and
insights about the world so the second
big area that we're seeing major
innovation from enterprises is in
optimizing their core business one of
our core strengths and maps is
increasingly becoming our understanding
of real-time traffic data and many
businesses especially those that are in
the business of moving things in the
world tap into this rich data to help
streamline their operation
and optimize their workforce so from
transport and logistics companies to
things like emergency relief and
disaster response we're seeing more and
more organizations putting maps at the
center of their operations and helping
them more efficiently locate manage and
monitor their resources it's one example
fleet minder used the Google Maps API is
to build are starting to map their
vehicle locations so their dispatchers
could view where they were and send them
real-time updates as things were
changing and what we saw from them is
that is that this drove direct savings
that went right to their bottom line so
to give you an example their CIO has
told us that by using Google's mapping
solutions it's helped them cut their
inefficient driving in half and has
helped reduce incorrect deliveries that
they were providing by 20% but now build
on little build on that a little further
and let's imagine what's possible when
that real-time traffic understanding can
get baked much more deeply into your
systems or as we're beginning to be able
to do also predict what traffic or
movement might look like under different
conditions in the real world in the
future imagine being able to ask things
like how many extra taxis should I have
at 5:00 p.m. in New York on a Thursday
when the Yankees are playing or can I
guarantee a 15-minute delivery window to
my customers when there's a Beyonce
concert happening in LA on Thursday
night
these are increasingly the types of
questions that customers are asking us
to help them with they want to optimize
them route their fleets better based on
changing conditions in the real world
and we're really excited to be giving
more and more businesses the insights
that they need to flexibly respond to
real time real world conditions
finally our deep understanding of
location combined with machine learning
in the cloud provides incredible
potential to help enterprises make smart
strategic decisions an example is a
German insurance company called wgv
insurance and they created a risk map on
top of our data to understand both where
their policyholders are and help them
model with different risk management
scenarios so in less than six weeks they
were able to take their policyholder
information
overlay it together with things like
flood areas weather reports and other
types of geo data to help them make
better decisions about how to
financially model their business and I
think it's a testament to the power of
this sort of data and tooling that they
were able to fundamentally shift how
they did risk assessment modeling in
such a short period of time we also see
a lot of businesses asking questions
about the real world that I that they
don't have answers to or that they're
spending very very heavily on physical
infrastructure to answer and this is a
big area where our understanding of how
the world moves can help influence
important commercial decisions out there
in the physical world so give you one
example we're currently in conversations
with a major city that traditionally has
spent hundreds of millions of dollars on
things like putting sensors in their
roads are sending surveys out to homes
to find out things about traffic and
commuting patterns and we're talking to
them now about how they can instead use
our real-time traffic data machine
learning and predictive analytics to
help make urban planning decisions
easier faster more accurate and very
importantly far far less expensive it's
just one example of how our rich data
and analytics capabilities can really
drive change and the way companies go
about gathering information about
physical movement in the world just two
weeks ago we announced the acquisition
of urban engines who built a location
analytics business around use cases like
transit and transportation we want to be
able to help answer questions like where
are the where are the next areas of
urban sprawl going to be and can we use
that information to decide where to
build the next highway or where I should
put my next retail store or even how
much retail staff should I plan to have
on hand next Friday night based on what
the predicted level of foot traffic
nearby is going to be we're really
excited about the new opportunities that
this deep location intelligence can fuel
building on top of this rich
comprehensive understanding of the
physical world and how it moves over the
last decade Google Maps has made some
incredible strides and yet I really
quite honestly feel like we're just at
the beginning of something new
even more exciting it's particularly
exciting to me that the types of
problems that businesses are looking to
us to help them solve are exponentially
more challenging than they were even a
few years back you know a few years ago
most of the conversations we were having
the businesses around things like how
can we help them visualize the real
world how could we do things like show
some custom data on top of a map but
today enterprises are increasingly
asking us about much more sophisticated
location problems ones that involve
planning spending insights movements
predictions in essence we're helping
businesses move beyond just visualizing
the world and helping them make major
real world decisions and at the center
of it all is location and it's
understanding how the real world moves
so you've heard today the combination of
our raw location understanding and
movement data from the billion users of
our consumer products combined with
Google's machine learning and cloud
compute power can change the game very
very quickly for a lot of industries
from retail to real estate
transportation to logistics and more so
if you or your customers operate in the
physical world then location should
matter deeply to you and if it does we
invite you to talk to us what fuels our
imagination more than anything our
real-world problems and we love to
invite you all to a conversation with us
about what your business needs are and
the problems that you're most looking to
solve we're just at the beginning of
helping businesses unlock the potential
from this understanding of location and
we're very excited to partner with all
of you to bring these opportunities to
life thank you